so you competed in your first suggested
tournament and me as a fellow Jiu Jitsu
practitioner and competitor I think
that's really inspiring given all the
things you have going on so I gotta ask
what was that experience like oh it's
fun I don't know yeah I mean well look
I'm a pretty competitive person yeah
um doing sports that basically require
your full attention I think is really
important to my like mental health and
and the way I just stay focused at doing
everything I'm doing it's like I decided
to get into martial arts and it's um
it's awesome I got like a ton of my
friends into it we all trained together
um we have like a mini Academy in my
garage
um and I guess um and one of my friends
was like hey we should go do a
tournament I was like okay yeah let's do
it I'm not gonna shy away from a
challenge like that so yeah it was but
it was it was awesome it was it was just
a lot of fun you weren't scared there
was no fear I don't know I I was I was
pretty sure that I'd that I'd do okay I
like the confidence um well so for
people don't know no jiu jitsu is a
martial art where you're trying to break
your opponent's limbs or choke them to
sleep and do so with grace and elegance
and efficiency and all that kind of
stuff it's a uh it's a kind of art form
I think they can do for your whole life
and it's a basically a game a sport of
human chess you can think of there's a
lot of strategy there's a lot of sort of
interesting human dynamics of using
leverage and all that kind of stuff and
it's kind of incredible what you could
do you could you could do things like a
small opponent could defeat a much
larger opponent and you get to
understand like the way the mechanics of
the human body works because of that but
you certainly can't be distracted no
yeah it's it's a hundred percent Focus
yeah to to compete I I you know I need
to get around the fact that I didn't
want it to be like this this big thing
so basically just I rolled up with a hat
and sunglasses and I was wearing a
covered mask and I registered under my
first and middle name so Mark Elliott
and um and it wasn't until I actually
pulled all that stuff off right before I
got on the map that I think people knew
was me so it was it was pretty low-key
but you're still a public figure yeah I
mean I didn't want to lose right the
thing you're partially afraid of is not
just the losing but being almost like
embarrassed it's so raw the sport in
that like it's just you and another
human being there's a primal aspect
there oh yeah it's great for a lot of
people can be terrifying especially the
first time you're doing the competing
and you wasn't for you I see the look of
excitement in your face
I just think part of learning is failing
okay right so I mean the main thing like
people who who train Jiu Jitsu it's like
you need to not have pride because I
mean all the stuff you were talking
about before about
you know getting choked or getting you
know a joint lock it's um
you only get into a bad situation if
you're not willing to tap once you
you've already lost right and but
obviously when you're getting started
with something you're not going to be an
expert about it immediately so you just
need to to be willing to go with that
but I think this is like I don't know I
mean maybe I've just been embarrassed
enough times in my life yeah I I do that
there's a thing where like it has people
grow up maybe they don't want to be
embarrassed or anything they've built
their adult identity and they they kind
of have have a sense of of who they
they are and what they want to project
and I don't know I think maybe to some
degree
you know your ability to keep doing
interesting things is your willingness
to be embarrassed again and go back to
step one and start as a beginner and get
your ass kicked and you know look stupid
doing things and you know I think so
many of the things that we're doing
whether it's whether it's this I mean
this is just like a kind of a physical
part of my life but
um but running the company it's like we
just take on new adventures and
um
you know all the big things that we're
doing I think of as like 10 plus year
missions that we're on where you know
often early on you know people doubt
that we're gonna be able to do it and
the initial work seems kind of silly and
our whole ethos says we don't want to
wait until something is perfect to put
it out there we want to get it out
quickly and get feedback on it and so I
don't know I mean there's probably just
something about how I approach things in
there but I just kind of think that the
moment that you decide that you're going
to be too embarrassed to try something
new then you're not going to learn
anything anymore